well president Trump is calling Saudi
Arabia a great ally in warning against a
rush to judgment the president compares
the Khashoggi case to the sexual assault
allegations against Supreme Court
justice Brett Kavanaugh saying he
doesn't like the idea of guilty until
proven innocent in an interview he said
he wants to know what happened okay and
Saudi Arabia looking at it very strongly
and it depends whether or not the king
or the crown prince knew about it in my
opinion number one what happened but
whether or not they knew about it if
they knew about it that would be bad
major Garrett is at the White House with
the latest major good morning good
morning president Trump has given the
Saudis plenty of time every benefit of
the doubt and taken no visible steps on
behalf of the US government to seek
actual hard evidence about the
disappearance and possible murder of US
resident Washington Post contributor
Jamal khashoggi what the president has
done is repeated denials from the
highest levels of the Saudi government
including referring yesterday to a phone
call with a de facto leader Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman who told the
president who knew nothing about what
happened to Khashoggi now the
administration's approach continues to
defer to the Saudi timetable and the
Saudis approach to its own efforts at
fact-finding instead of demanding the
involvement of US investigators like the
FBI or endorsing what the khashoggi
family is called for an outside
internationally supervised independent
investigation
this approach leaves the unmistakable
impression the White House is doing all
it can to accommodate Saudi appeals for
time and Saudi efforts to explain if
they can what many fear is a high crime
and a brazen human rights violation the
pressure the president is facing growing
pressure on Capitol Hill even from some
Republican allies to denounce the Saudi
actions or at least be more skeptical of
Saudi explanations Lindsey Graham a
longtime ally of the White House said
that the crown prince is a toxic force
who cannot be a legitimate world leader
businesses are pulling back from the
Saudis diplomatic tensions are rising
and the administration feels very
stressed about this ongoing situation
John I
major Garrett thanks